But I mean,
the example I was using this in some of my colleagues have been broken by this
is,
you know,
the Syrian war has been very well covered.
Every crime has been very well documented,
you know,
often with video footage of exactly the crime being carried out as it made any
difference whatsoever.
I'm not sure.
The Syrian one is one where you hear,
you hear rational people say that like Assad is not our enemy and that how do
you,
what do you feel about that?
I mean,
I think with dealing with the legacy of the Iraq and Afghanistan wars in the,
even if you want to help,
what's the point?
You can't,
you're only gonna make it worse.
I think a lot of people feel that way and I think that leads some people to
think Assad is not a good guy.
He probably does have the blood of hundreds of thousands on his hands,
but we should deal with them anyway because that's better than Iraq or
Afghanistan is because when we do get rid of,
uh,
a leader like Libya with Gaddafi or Iraq with Hussein,
that what happens is you get this power vacuum and then it becomes far worse.
We've tried every model.
We've tried invading Afghanistan,
taking over,
trying to rebuild the entire culture and armed forces and government ourselves
that has failed miserably.
Try to rock Libya,
tried leading from the back,
um,
you know,
limited intervention,
hoping that the guys on the ground could do the fighting for us.
And then Syria,
we've tried almost no intervention whatsoever.
Um,
and all three have failed.
So I think now you've got people,
I mean,
the thing I always think most people would say we should have intervened in
Rwanda.
I think almost everyone would say,
I mean,
Bill Clinton would say that's his biggest regret,
I think in this presence.
And most people would say,
we should have intervened in Rwanda.
I think everyone to happen tomorrow.
You'd have a lot of people here saying it's not worth it.
We won't help.
We can't make the situation better.
So why even try?
Well,
it's so hard when you look at the rest of the world and you see these horrific
conditions and you see war lords in power and you see atrocities being committed
and we're sitting over here and you know,
in the valley watching on Internet and drinking Starbucks,
you know,
oh,
it's just Trump.
Go say,
well more so American American foreign coverage was never was never great.
No.
Now it's almost gone.
I mean Yemen,
we'll see.
I mean,
because of the crash Shoji murder may be,
maybe something can happen with Yemen cause and there is a lot we can do that
because we are directly supporting one side.
It almost seems like what you were talking about,
but in a far lesser extent,
the,
the feeling that you get when you're in these war zones that it's almost like
it's not real that you're,
you're covering it through this lens so you're immune from it.
It almost feels like we view the massive conflicts of the world that way.
They're like,
we're watching it on television,
we're seeing it on our phones or our laptops.
It's not,
it's real.
I know it's real.
It is.
It's a real issue,
but it's not real.
Look in terms of,
it's not knocking on my door.
Yeah.
No,
it's almost like we feel about it that way.
Yeah.
And the numbers as well.
I mean,
you know,
in Syria it could be 800,000 dead.
Um,
do people really think what that means?
What does 800,010 actually mean?
Do they win?
I think with certain numbers,
you,
you just,
they just become a,
just becomes digits and it just doesn't make sense.
Yeah.
It doesn't,
uh,
you look,
if you hear five guys get killed in a shootout,
you go walk this five guys were dead.
Yup.
And you start thinking about it.
You hear a 500,000 people died on the other side of the planet.
It's almost,
it almost doesn't register.
Yeah.
But for you or registers.
And you know,
I mean,
the reason I started doing this,
you know,
when I was a kid,
as soon as I started reading about these situations and,
and you know,
when I,
I remember reading that in my government,
the British government was arming,
you know,
often the wrong side.
Yeah.
And these conflicts,
I remember thinking,
how is this not fun page news,
right?
How is everyone not talking about this every single day?
And I still feel like that now even though I'm clearly out of step with,
you know,
most of the population.
But what you are so immersed is it hard for you when you come back and you see
the Trump gossip and all the nonsense and all the things that we engage in on a
daily basis here in America that are really trivial at best.
I mean,
you know,
is it hard for you to,
I mean,
you mean you,
you get to see the worst shit happening in the world all the time.
Is it hard for you to relate?
Yeah,
I mean,
you,
you know,
I mean,
one of the,
one of the main symptoms I had of,
of the PTSD from covering this for so long was,
was it was numbness to physical danger when I was there,
but it was numbness when I got back home.
So you'd come back and you know,
at one point you used to think,
if I come back with the footage I have of whatever conflict,
it's going to have some kind of impact.
It's going to create some kind of ripple,
right.
And you come back and you think it's going to be,
there's going to be nothing.
The film's going to go out as a few people are going to tweet.
A few people are gonna,
you know,
send me a message that that's it.